many fans of one piece predict that
someday marco the phoenix will die and
be reborn in the series but what if i
told you that he already has right now
it's hot hot summer or winter depending
when and where you're watching this
really anyways summer the season of
backyard barbecues and it's time to
slice up one of our favorite most
shareable fruits nope i'm not talking
about watermelons i'm talking about our
very favorite pineapple marco the
phoenix by the way did you know that an
old name for pineapple in japanese is
the phoenix pier that goes oda once
again never missing an opportunity for
some good old wordplay but the real
question remains does marco belong on
pizza okay i'm done i'm done marco the
phoenix has been a fan favorite one
piece character ever since his debut in
the fifth sixth and seven one piece
popularity polls this character was
ranked 12th 20th and 19th respectively
and it's pretty impressive to break the
top 20 in a series with well over 1 000
named characters in fact he is the
second most popular whitebeard pirate
just after ace how about whitebeard oh
his own captain the strongest man in the
world whitebeard himself only made 30
first place in the latest poll sure
edward newgate has been absent from the
series for over a decade ever since his
untimely death but the strongest man in
the world surely made an impression on
the fanbase to say the least and i
really should say that marco's been a
fan favorite ever since his proper debut
once we got to see him in action at the
paramount war his cameo as the
background character during whitebeards
and shanks's meeting hardly counts i
think not only was his character not
flashed out yet but even his hair color
wasn't even pinned down yet it seems and
so we had yet to know the sheer volume
of cool that would ooze from this
character's amazing devil fruit power
the toritorinomi model of phoenix was
the very first mythical zone fruit that
we were ever introduced to in the entire
series followed soon after by sengoku's
golden buddha fruit and now we're not
counting the nika fruit since it wasn't
formally introduced until very recently
so why exactly is marco so loved by us
fans sure he has an awesome power but
that alone can't justify his wild wild
popularity among a cast with so many
fantastically written characters i mean
not only does he outrank whitebeard
among the fanbase but heavy hitters like
blackbeard garp and even doflamingo it's
not just the powers of the phoenix but
the meaning behind the phoenix as a
animal and how marco embodies that
meaning that delivers his characters to
such extreme heights
the heights of popularity not the kind
of heights he achieves by flying i guess
that's obvious so yeah someday in the
final saga we may get to see marco die
and resurrect literally as many predict
the phoenix fruit will allow him to do
however i want to theorize that in a way
marco has already died and resurrected
and in doing so has shown what it really
takes to be the first mate of an emperor
of the sea also quick shout out to
patricia and austin singer both of whom
are subscribed to the channel and thus
have helped us increase our bouncy by
100 barries each advancing us on our
shared mission to overtake trebled
bounty and reach 100 million berries so
zorro rayleigh katakuri marco so often
in one piece the first mates are the
coolest characters on their cruise and
in the story overall if we're being
honest many fans included would rank
zorro as their favorite straw hat over
luffy due to his epic three sword style
feats rayleigh stopped an admiral slight
speed kick with a sandal katakuri's
design initially looked so edgy that he
seemed to be out of place in one piece
but quickly became a beloved antagonist
and when i say that these characters are
cool i don't just mean they're awesome
which they are these characters all have
subdued personalities partnered with
effortless feats of brutal strength all
of them are laid back in the face of
immense danger and they just ooze
coolness but is that what really makes a
great first mate
no it takes a lot more than being cool
to be the first mate to the world's
greatest pirates each of these pirates
carries the burden when their captain no
longer can in other words when the
number one is absent or incapacitated
they are the leaders to their crews they
inherit the will of their captains when
luffy was unconscious on thriller bark
zoro took on his pain in order to save
the crew and he did so unselfishly
proclaiming that nothing happened after
roger's execution rayleigh waited
decades on saba odi until he found his
captain's successor he trained luffy so
that he would stand a chance on the
journey ahead in a new world and
eventually could find love tale during
big mom's hunger pains when she destroys
her own island and even devours her own
children it's katakuri who protects his
family members at all costs and so of
course marco also carries on the will of
whitebeards and in doing so he embodies
the spirit of his devil fruit the
phoenix in the legend of the phoenix
this fiery bird makes its nest and then
dies engulfed in flames from the ashes
that remain it is reborn as an egg
hatching again into a new phoenix which
is also why we have to ask ourselves at
this point in the story whether baron
tamago has a technically more accurate
phoenix fruit than marco does on a more
serious note though it's fitting that
this story would fit so neatly into
mythology after all we do know that oda
loves drawing on various myths and
legends from all around the world the
journey of the phoenix can be found in
legends from all types of countries and
places the journey of marco actually
parallels a literal concept called the
monomyth the scholar joseph campbell in
his book the hero with a thousand faces
recognized that many myths and legends
from across the world do share similar
structures this shared common structure
for stories is called the monomyth or
the hero's journey one focal part of the
hero's journey comes after a great
challenge they fall into an abyss an
absolute low point a death and a rebirth
ultimately after their rebirth they rise
into overcoming their challenges and
finding atonement and so of course the
entirety of luffy's story for instance
mirrors the hero's journey very well as
well his lowest point was losing his
brother at marine ford a period of utter
despair and hopelessness that he was
then reborn from after the time skip but
we also see this concept represented in
miniature with marco and the legend of
the phoenix in general after the war at
marineford when the white pit pirates
lost both their captain and ace marco
stepped up to the role of leader as a
new captain he sought vengeance against
blackbeard the traitor who had caused
unspeakable damage to his former crew
however in this payback war the remnants
of the whitebeard pirates suffered a
devastating loss and subsequently had to
disband and so if marco's journey
parallels the mythology of the phoenix
then this is his death well once he
soared into battle he went out in a
blaze of glory seemingly completely
defeated it was then that he retreated
to things island even after the end of
his crew he never lost sight of
fulfilling his captain's will marco
protected the island that whitebeard
considered his treasure using his
medical knowledge to take care of the
people there and watching over the
graves of ace and his captain even
though his personal battle had ended
embers remained in the ashes still
burning softly with the dreams of the
late edward new gates and so it was of
course in wano that the phoenix would
rise once again reunited with another
former division commander izo marco
returned to the battlefields after
hearing nekomamushi's plea for help he
knew it's what whitebeard would have
done to help avenge his old friend
kozuki odin now with stylish new glasses
which you know we could see as a new
clarity of vision at the risk of maybe
overanalyzing this a little bit you know
let's do it anyways marco's phoenix form
burned again clashing with some of the
great powers of the world the commanders
of two yonko crews and briefly with big
mom herself his healing powers came in
clutch during the battle and he even
helped zorro make it in time to
participate in roof piece many fans also
see marco as the pheasant parallel
within the momotaro myth in which
momonosuke restored his kingdom with the
help of a monkey luffy a dog yamato and
the pheasant which is marco the phoenix
played an invaluable role in the ninja
pirate mink samurai alliance and likely
helped turn the tide of the battle for
wano country now it's still unknown to
us what will actually become of marco in
the final saga but surely there is more
to his story as far as we know
whitebeard's supposed sun weevil is
still hunting the remnants of the wiper
pirates will he eventually restore this
crew to the form of glory finally making
a true rebirth will the rest of the
division commanders that we haven't seen
post timeskip make an appearance maybe
there's still hope too that the
figurative death and rebirth that marco
has followed in the story so far will be
followed by a literal death
and rebirth enabled by his mythical zone
fruit and who knows maybe he will even
sail with the straw hats for a little
bit in a recent video on this channel
the phoenix fruit was actually named the
most powerful of all the zone devil
fruits and if you want to know the
secret to why it is the best of the best
and see what fruit it narrowly beat you
really should miss out on that video
right here